speaking of things that cost a lot but  are super exciting  uh page two  crap no we're we'll wrap it up  calm down this is there's more than page  two what do you think this is  this is uh jesus  well louis de broyley's thesis was three  pages long and he won the nobel prize  for the wave particle duality  so you know size  matters in different dimensions in life  i think the the lessons i've learned  about life is the shorter the paper or  the shorter the thesis  uh actually the shorter the paper some  of the greatest papers ever written are  sure like i feel like uh  some of the best ideas in this world  not to sound like a contradiction of  feynman a contradiction on top of a  contradiction but it could be written on  a napkin honestly  um it's just kind of it tells you  something about ideas  you